So, I wonder who asked about this place?
Yes, Mr.Tarren, ah, if he introduced me, do
n't worry. Even before that, there were rumors that Nakami-ya in Kankin Shinjuku
is famous among the Koroshi community. The
rules are relaxed and it's a comfortable place.  Well,
that's an honor. You were Shibuya's ace, and it's great that you and your
brothers are praising you. Hiro Shima. I
don't remember telling you my real name even in Shibuya.
But, I'm sorry, it was easy to find out, so I
don't think you're hiding it.  The rules are
lenient, but I'm afraid that you'll be punished if you do something.Maybe you have a
bad personality.Thank you,
Clarissa.You're
so cute from the inside out.It's welcome to have more people taking on your work.It
looks like you're going to be busy with a lot of things.
Shine